it will reduce our deficit by more than
100 billion dollars over the next decade
and more than one trillion dollars in
the decade after that not only is the
legislation unlikely to cut record-level
spending shortfalls by one thin dime
it's likely to cost taxpayers a lot more
than the 940 billion dollars in new
spending for at least three reasons the
legislation just passed doesn't include
what's known as the doc fix a permit
upward adjustment to the rates at which
Medicare providers are reimbursed
originally part of the House bill it was
split in two separate legislation to
reduce the cost of reform but both
senate majority leader harry reid and
house speaker nancy pelosi have said
that the fix will be in later this year
it's costs as the government will be two
hundred and forty seven billion dollars
over the next ten years destroying any
possible savings from health care reform
in 2006 Massachusetts passed a plan very
similar to the one just passed by
Congress including a mandate that
everybody buy coverage but far from
bringing down prices by shoving younger
healthier people into risk pools the
base state now suffers the highest
premiums in the country and the cost is
running about a third higher than
anticipated
governments do an awful job of
predicting just how much money they're
going to spend especially on medical
care initial projections of medicare's
costs in its first quarter century were
off by a long shot it was supposed to
cost 12 billion dollars in 1990 instead
the cost came in at almost ten times
that figure as a report by the Joint
Economic Committee puts it since World
War two major health care proposals have
almost always cost more than the highest
cost estimates published while the
legislation was pending under estimating
expenses isn't a bug it's a feature of
government health care plans for reason
TV I'm Nicholas
you